sure I think there's a difference
between saying I would do something
personally and thinking one should be
able to do it and I think there are two
reasons for this one people who oppose
the possibility and the technology for
the most part isn't really there yet
letting people choose the sexual
orientation of their children assume
that this will lead to more straight
children and fewer gay children I'm not
at all convinced this is the case if a
small percentage of people choose to
have straight children because they
would otherwise be bigoted or they
otherwise were bigoted and don't want to
have gay children but a large percentage
of gay people choose to have gay
children and the average likelihood have
been randomly distorted child being gays
somewhere between 2 and 10 percent on
the whole the number of gay people will
actually increase rather than decrease
so I think that's a red herring argument
the real concern I have is I want people
to be born into families didn't want
them on an individual basis as a
utilitarian philosopher I think the
least suffering we have the better and
my concern is for the potential gay
child borgin to the bigoted family who
mistreats that child to disowns that
child who drives their child to suicide
and Matt to me that suffering is far
more concerning than the possibility
that we won't force more progressive
cultural values than people who don't
want them well I wouldn't certainly make
that choice personally I can also
understand why a parent might say I'm
deeply opposed to homophobia I think the
world should be a fair equal place but
the reality is I also want the best for
my children I understand that people
discriminate against gays and lesbians I
don't want my child to be discriminated
against until the revolution occurs and
there is equality I want my children to
have the best opportunities I wouldn't
necessarily justify that sexual
orientation I think that's a reasonable
philosophy to apply to race religion
ethnicity any characteristic I should
add I don't think many people will make
that choice I don't think it on the
whole lower social diversity but I think
it will do is guarantee that people who
do have children who are more diverse
want those children
I think the research I miss is still a
rapidly evolving but there will be some
genetic components homosexuality there
clearly is some hormonal component in
the wound there well there may be some
environmental component too we simply
don't know yet
I do think over the course of time we
will be able to unravel
whatever the complex web of causes of
homosexuality or for that matter
heterosexuality are and once we can do
that then parents are gonna have to face
the choice and they should be able to
make a choice what kinds of child they
want I should add I've already written
in the past but I think parent should be
able to choose what we want to have male
children or female children I think in
this country not many people would do
that and I think the only limitation on
that should be if there is a mass
structural dislocation so I can
understand why India might require
parents to not might prevent parents for
making the choice because of the fear of
having a overwhelming number of men in
relation to women I would be far more
pressed to say Sweden without those same
cultural concerns should be allowed to
do this I would also add for what it's
worth that in cultures where there may
be people who choose to have male
children or straight children they're
outliers like me who if they did make a
choice might choose to have female
children or gay children that would
balance things out